let's talk about Fox News in a sort of
bigger picture way Fox News is making
the decision either knowingly or or by
sort of default to become Trump TV and
it's sort of sad we didn't know which
way Fox News was going to go and it's
very clear at this point Rupert Murdoch
after megyn kelly decided to leave for
NBC announced that Tucker Carlson would
be taking over Megyn Kelly's 9 p.m. slot
slot a big Trump supporter so this is
one of the many signs that Rupert
Murdoch is moving Fox in the pro Trump
direction we are also seeing generally
that there was there was one point I
don't remember exactly when it was Pat I
think it was actually surrounding the
Trump megyn kelly she's bleeding from
her genitals a dust-up where it wasn't
really clear whether Fox was going to
take an establishment Republican anti
Trump approach or whether they were
going to just fully Buy in with the pro
Trump stuff it's becoming pretty clear
now that they're going pro Trump isn't
it well I mean that makes sense because
Fox News and bio is by and large a
mouthpiece for the Republican Party and
the Republican Party itself was in
disarray at that time Tucker Carlson
good relationship with Donald Trump the
network is fawning over Tucker Carlson
than in our network is fining over
Donald Trump and etc and megyn kelly was
really different than that and even
whatever you believe about Megyn Kelly's
personal politics and to be honest I
don't know what to believe I've heard
interviews with her where she says you
know I am liberal on a lot of things and
on some other issues I'm conservative
and by and large I think she was playing
a character on Fox News I'm curious to
see whether she plays a totally
different character on NBC it is
becoming abundantly clear that the
primetime hours of Fox News are going in
the pro-trump
direction and ratings wise I don't know
what's going to happen with Tucker
Carlson but we know that the five on Fox
News is doing really well and that is a
comically Pro Trump show sometimes not
overtly but implicitly in everything
they do it's very Pro Trump you also
have the at least temporary
scheduling of Sean Hannity and Bill
O'Reilly that will be sandwich Inge some
of these other programs Sean Hannity
doing his totally pro-trump apologia
going to interview Julian Assange in a
completely friendly way Assange now
instead of being the enemy of the right
is the friend of the right now that his
narrative supports that Trump is a
legitimate president so Fox News we were
thinking about it front losses will he
create Trump TV seems like he wouldn't
really even have to it would kind of be
redundant given what we're going to see
on fox news for the next four years and
if I was to make a prediction regarding
their ratings I would guess that they
would go down somewhat because in part
because their audiences aging that
demographic that watches Fox News is in
their sixties and seventies but also
because I think it's less entertaining
and people tune in less to see someone
criticized the current administration
rather than to praise them that's
interesting and the idea of you attract
more people as opposition media to
whoever is in office I'm a well what I
meant to say there but yet you want to
tune in when someone's criticizing the
president no yeah I mean it both of them
are both both are correct right you
might tune in less when the network is
seen as friendly to the administration
or you might tune in more when the
network is seen as adversarial to the
administration if you don't like the
administration that's part of what I'm
seeing with the David Pakman show right
I mean there's no doubt that the
increased interest in the show and the
accelerated rate of membership
subscriptions and the entire thing since
Trump was elected part of it is that now
progressives see we need to support
opposition media and the truth is we've
been very critical of much of what
President Obama has done over the last
eight years but it feels often like you
want to tune in more when you want to
see what's the opposition narrative and
we'll see if that impacts Fox News I
think there's a lot there to what you're
saying
today's show is brought to you by go
daddy where you can buy your own domain
name build a website or use any of Go
Daddy's business tools you can save 30%
at try go daddy.com slash David GoDaddy
has actually been the official host of
the David Pakman show website for many
many many years the 24
customer support has been a very good
thing for us I've called them at really
odd times when we've had website issues
and they are always available they are
the largest domain registrar and whether
you have a new idea you're an
established business you're creating a
personal website or moving your large
enterprise site over to GoDaddy they can
do it all thirteen million customers try
it and get 30% off at try go daddy.com
slash David